hello everyone and welcome to round
three of the charity cup uh it is
pragananda versus magnus carlsen a lot
of you guys requested this game even
before it finished as it was incredibly
interesting so now let's dive straight
into it and uh see if pragernanda can
beat magnus twice in a row so as we know
we he defeated him in the
air things masters a month ago if you
still haven't seen that game it's really
an enjoyable one he defeated magnus with
the black pieces it will be the first
link in the description below so maybe
even check that out before watching this
if you still haven't seen it but now
getting to this game uh let's uh let's
just enjoy so prague has the white
pieces and he opens with d4 so what will
magnus go for
knight to f6 c4 g6 knight to c3 and now
d5 magnus goes for the groomfield
defense uh and anything is possible now
c captures on the e5 knight captures an
e4 we go for the main line knight
captures on c3 b captures and bishop the
g7 so so far everything is perfectly
normal knight to f3 and black strikes
against the center with c5 as the black
usually does in this variation bishop to
e3 bishop to g4 attacking the knight
here not allowing it to move and rook to
c1 uh very standard idea as the rook is
uh well somewhat vulnerable on a1 you
will have problems pushing eighth uh d5
as long as the the rook is on a1 so here
magnus castles with bishop to e2 and now
queen to a5 putting pressure on this c3
pawn so as we know this is much like
every other opening is a fight for the
center so black is trying to play c
captures on d4 uh so it will be very
good for him and the white will of
course always make it impossible for
black to do that because well it will
not be good for him so here uh prague
castles and the queen captures an a2
this is a known pawn sacrifice and it's
not uh nothing new yeah magnus carlsen
even played it himself in 2015 against
maxime bashar lagrave in the tata still
chess tournament although that game
ended in a draw and in that game rook to
b1 was played however some other moves
are known in this position rook the b1
is known like we said in the carlson mvl
game rook to a1 is a known move a bishop
to g5 is a known move h3 is a known move
so all of these are known ideas however
the move prague makes is a new move uh
he plays d5 and now already as of move
12 we have a completely new game so
let's see how magnus deals with this he
played knights to d7 fairly quickly and
now you can see that he has a past a
pawn so he might be interested in
playing b5 a5
for the moment that's not easily
achieved he first had to defend his c5
pawn and that the b5 square is guarded
by the bishop so you first have to make
some preparations before you start
pushing and as you can imagine white
will have a very very strong center
if he is able to push all of these pawns
forward so here we have h3 and magnus
plays bishop captures on f3 uh
eliminating the knight and now not
bishop captures an f3 if you play bishop
captures yes your king side the remains
intact but then black can immediately
start with b5 so the bishop for the
moment is needed here guarding this
square so prague instead plays g
captures on f3 and now queen to a5 by
magnus regarding the b5 square so now b5
can be played but also putting pressure
on this c3 pawn
and here prague played queen to d2 now
this is where things get extremely
interesting uh because queen to d3 seems
to be a bit more precise than queen to
d2 but um i it's hard to realize why
if if you don't know so i will show it
uh queen to d3 has to be played because
now uh c4
which is the the main idea
against queen to d2 cannot be played
here we just captured the pawn and once
we activate the rook rotate the c8 queen
to b4 can be played that's the whole
point however here prague does defend
the pawn but now magnus goes for this uh
will a very interesting positional pawn
sacrifice but now if bishop captures on
c4 then we play rook 8 to c8 attack the
bishop and once the bishop moves now we
play bishop captures on c3 so much much
different than the line that we've
discussed if the queen was on d3 and
then the queen can go to b4 but still
queen to d3 and the game continues uh
well it's definitely playable for both
of them prague still has the bishop pair
and it's not going to be all that easy
to push those past pawns
so instead like i said after uh this c4
move uh prague plays queen to b2 and now
uh he uh has some very nice threats for
one he's attacking the b7 pawn uh
another thing magnus always has to
worry about rook to a1 if rook a1
attacks the queen what do you do then
okay obviously we capture here but then
comes the question if b5 rook to a1 okay
we capture here but then we lose the b5
pawn so that has to be calculated as
well and this is a rapid game so not all
that uh much time to calculate and uh uh
queen to c7 is a safer move uh you
defend the c for c4 pawn you will
prepare b5 and for example something
like queen to c7 we defend our pawn then
white will play f4 of course e5 is
coming we're going to play a6 prepare
our b5 move and after this
rook c to d1 uh b5 will be played now
comes e5 and white uh black has this
beautiful expansion on the queen side
whereas prague would have this beautiful
expansion in the center of the board so
it's definitely a trade-off but uh he is
still down upon so that is definitely
something to to consider
uh so instead after queen to b2 magnus
decides that there's no need to do that
let's go for the immediate b5 very
aggressive and okay prague now could
choose between two ideas he could go for
rook to a1 which is what happened in the
game or try to close off the dark square
bishop with f4 and e5
prague decides to go for rook day one
and now we have a trade here queen
captures on c3 now comes a queen
captures on b5 grabbing that pawn and
knight to b6 now this is how magnus very
interestingly defends the c for pawn and
he says i'm keeping my extra pawn there
is nothing you can do about it
because if you capture with the knight
i'm going to play a captures on b6 and
now i'm threatening to pick up your rook
here with rook capture so you don't have
time to capture on c4 so here we would
have to trade once for example captures
captures now we can capture the pawn but
now it's not all that great queen to d2
of course now we avoid the queen trade
because the white's king side is all
messed up and it will be very very hard
to play this uh for example we put a
queen on g5 deliver checking f1 bishop
e5 this will be
impossible to defend for white
so those are only some of the ideas but
uh you you can't go for this so instead
rook ate the c1 attacking the queen here
queen to f6 again magnus doesn't allow
the capture of the pawn because now the
f3 pawn would be hanging so prague plays
king to g2 now defends the pawn
threatens to pick up the c4 pawn but now
magnus pushes it to c3 and now it is
beautifully defended here uh but uh can
can he keep defending it prague says
nope i'm gonna play f4 e5 and then i'm
gonna just pick up this pawn and then
i'm still gonna have the bishop pair
with equal material on the board uh and
the magnus strikes with e5 and this is
uh this is a great move i will however
show uh a most interesting idea that
starts with queen to h4 and now asking
white what do you do and if white
continues with the plan of e5 then we
have this very annoying g6 idea which
not only threatens g captures on f4 but
also weakens the e5 pawn so something to
consider maybe and if we can continue
let's say d6 g captures on f4 d captures
on e7 going after the rook uh let's say
queen captures here bishop captures here
let's say rook 8 to c8 now we again have
a defense of the c3 pawn but now the
black's
[Music]
position also opens up a little bit
white still has the bishop pair the
queens on the board if the rooks double
up here could be also very very
dangerous for magnus so and also it's
too much to calculate for rapid so
magnus just pushes e5 uh we have d
captures on e6 alpha song now if if of
course you go for the f captures on e5
then after queen captures you really
have nothing to show for here with white
the pawn is just defended the black will
uh just activate those rooks and that's
pretty much it so instead after e5d
captures on e6 this is the absolute best
queen captures on e6 and now e5 and now
the c3 pawn is an undefended we are
ready to capture it the situation on the
clock is three minutes for prague and
six minutes for magnus and here magnus
goes for knight to d5 he still doesn't
allow the pawn to be captured uh but
there also is this a very tricky g5 move
now again i will show it because it's
super fun even though it would be
impossible uh to calculate with so
little time on the clock the idea is
after rook captures on c3 g captures on
f4 and after bishop captures now knight
d5 attacking the rook and the bishop and
well this is all fairly simple for both
of them to calculate after rook to c3
it's not all that easy rook to f3 it's
not all that easy to evaluate this
knight captures with check rook captures
queen captures and now yes you've opened
up the white king but uh the black king
isn't uh
all that safe either and also we can
just trade queens for example queen
captures bishop captures rook to f5 and
yes black is up upon but his bishops of
opposite color there is not much to look
for here now so it is uh interesting uh
maybe magnus calculated all of it maybe
who knows but uh he decided for knight
to d5
uh we have bishop to g4 going after the
queen here and now how do you play this
here magnus plays a most interesting
knight captures on e3 there are some
ideas with rook a to b8 but uh
it all pretty much uh
goes down to the same idea knight
captures an e3 with check f captures an
e3 and now queen to 80 with check as f
captures on e3 opened up this
possibility rook to f2 blocking this and
now queen to a3 so again defending the
c3 pawn so magnus is doing absolutely
everything he can
to keep this pawn alive rook after c2
prague again ready to capture it rook
ate the b8 now attacking the queen
finally queen to c4 now the pawn is
attacked three times but now magnus
plays rook to b2 again
prevents the capture of the c3 pawn with
a tactic because if you capture it then
we can simply capture the queen the the
rook is pinned the rook cannot capture
the queen
and here uh prague played all of his
moves extremely quickly and the time
pretty much evened out probably was down
to some two and a half minutes on the
clock magnus some three minutes on the
clock
and here we have
after king to g3 we have h5 and this is
the start of something beautiful uh
bishop to f3 uh just moving the bishop
okay you could consider and maybe
capturing the pawn first but there's
nothing wrong with capturing it later
and now magnus plays h4 uh very very
tricky of course the pawn cannot be
captured if the pawn is captured then
bishop captures an e5 comes and you are
never capturing the c3 pawn with white
we are winning this game with black
there's no question about it and of
course if you capture the bishop then
just to appear the queen and king are
now on the same fourth rank
unfortunately for white
so
the h4 pawn cannot be captured king back
to h2 uh and now comes rook to d8 ready
to bring the other rook into the attack
uh and then now comes bishop to d5
prague blocks the attack while also
attacking the f7 pawn uh here for very
specific reasons uh king the g2 is a
move that has to be played but um okay
we can even show it i know you guys
really want me to show it the problem is
now carlson's idea of rook captures rook
captures and queen to a1 check can be
met with queen to f1 and now you either
trade and you don't really have all that
much or you go back queen to a5 uh or
rather queen to a3 and we play queen to
c4 uh
black will have to keep looking for
other ways to continue playing this but
there doesn't seem to be all that many
and still c3 pawn is under attack uh
however prague played the very active
bishop to d5 he goes after the f7 pawn
but now magnus just plays king to h7 and
now how do you continue this uh again
it's a very very difficult to find a
move here king to g2 has to be played
here uh but prague played king the g1
and this allows magnus a very very
beautiful idea
which is an incredibly difficult one to
calculate so feel free to pause the
video and try to solve this one if you
solve it i promise you you will be uh
you know proud of yourself for at least
a month
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is rook
captures on c2 rook captures on c2 all
of you guys saw this queen the a1 check
hence king the g2 was much much better
than king to g1 king to g2 now and queen
to d1 attacking the rook now and the
bishop on d5 is attacked now twice so
the only way for white to play this is
bishop to e4 uh to guard the rook but
now there are many ways you can win this
for example rook to d to check is one of
them rook captures we're going to play c
captures on d2 now this pawn is already
uh just a monster bishop to c2 we have
to keep an eye on the queening square
and now queen to e1 we're gonna play
queen to d4 because we have to prevent
the pawn from queening but now let's see
if we need to check king to h1 and queen
f2 we are going to deliver check check
pick up this pawn create the past h pawn
and it doesn't matter really what white
plays the position is now completely
winning for black however with uh so
little time on the clock magnus misses
the idea he plays queen to a5 forces
prague to waste time for his moves and
now prague will plays e4 he defends his
bishop here on d5 whereas the only
possible continuation was bishop
captures on f7 uh again okay we can show
it because it's super interesting uh
magnus would play rook captures on c2
rook captures and after queen to a1 with
check we can play king f2 and now after
rook to d to check there's rook capture
spawn captures and now bishop captures
and g6 so this was the only way to play
this now you can see that these pawns
are extremely powerful and after the
king moves uh capturing the bishop would
just allow the white queen to deliver
too many checks bishop back to c2 and
now there is uh not much more because
after queenie one check yes you can play
all of these checks king h1 queen
captures here kings you want queen g3
check you're gonna play queen h1 and now
once you try to do something let's say
queen e1 checking h2 there's no way for
you to bring the queen into the game
because if you do this uh you run into
queen e6 check and now look at these
squares are covered there's no way for
the king to go you have to go here and
this you can even run into checkmate so
now bishop captures an f7 the only way
to continue fighting pretty much or
bishop t for bishop captures on f7 is
better but after e4 it is now winning
for magnus because now magnus just plays
queen to b6 check this is the idea of
bringing the queen to a5 queen to b6 and
then uh remaneuvering the queen over to
e3 where he will be able to hit all of
these weak squares so king g2 queen to
e3 now going after queen to g3 we have
queen to f1 and now even bishop to h6 uh
threatening to pick up the f4 pawn king
to h1 and now bishop captures on f4
there's no way for you to defend
everything at least you're defending the
h3 pawn uh rook captures on b2 c
captures on b2 and rook to b1 and now
magnus plays queen to g3 he's
threatening queen to h2 checkmate rook
captures on b2 uh he gives up the b2
pawn which seems like something you
don't want to do but now comes rook to
c8 now rook to c1 is the threat of just
picking up the queen and you can't bring
the rook back if you bring the rook back
then you are no longer guarding against
checkmate so you can to defend both the
c1 and checkmate prago tried e6 he has
to play something he is extremely low on
time rook to c1 and there goes the queen
queen captures on c1 but now not the
automatic captures
first queen captures an h3 we have to
play the most precise moves until the
end the king g1 now bishop captures on
c1 and he was in this position on mu 43
that program resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
so incredible game uh a lot of people
thought that uh he would get his second
win in hero against the magnus carlsen
uh and you can see that he played
incredible chess but magnus just kept uh
finding the absolute craziest ideas of
how to defend that c3 pawn uh it was uh
just just incredible of course he
resigns here because he is without a
queen and there's really not not much
point in continuing uh your rook is
hanging and let's say you try something
like rogue b7 okay you can play
something like this bishop e3 is
checkmate only only one of the ideas but
anything else loses as well
but it's so interesting how long after
all of this this pawn survived so it
came here on move 20 and it remained
there until
magnus finally was able to push it so he
was defending it for the entire game
basically the theme of the game was
defending and attacking the c3 pawn
prague tried to want it back magnus was
defending it and in the end magnus just
like that here as you as you can see uh
just after capturing it uh gave it up
uh for for this beautiful idea of rook
to c8 so that's uh how chess works uh
it's basically transferring one type of
advantage into another type of advantage
so the past pawn was threatening to
become a queen but here for tactical
purposes we gave it up even though it's
an incredibly strong asset and now of
course there is no defense
so a brilliant brilliant game by both of
them but this time it was magnus who was
victorious
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it a little bit longer analysis
with all the sidelines but as they are
so interesting we can't skip them even
if we wanted to uh so yeah once again i
really hope you enjoyed it i would like
to thank t musa kojo now lucas falcao
aradelli christie maloney and ovidio
alexa for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
incredible uh tournament um and of
course checking up on your wonderful
suggestions so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day